hey Theo this is Tim from Philadelphia
what's the deal with all you can eat
wings man I went to the bar the other
day me and my lady and I wasn't sure if
we should order one or you can eat wings
if we were allowed to share them or was
that a violation we're gonna get kicked
out
uh yeah so we ordered two
and we we did eat enough but I wanted
more to go and I only had two left
look dude here's the thing if you got
that you know that Bonnie and Clyde type
lady
you know if you've got that little
Daredevil bad [__] and she don't mind
you know getting that one you know 21.99
and one you know she got to sit there
and pretend like she ain't having any
wings
even though she having them here's the
thing if you take a lady to a wing place
first of all
I that's kind of shady bro take your
lady to a nicer place where they got a
little bit of fish you know what I'm
saying buy that [__] I finish dinner
buy your lady a fish dinner
because some ladies want a fish they
want that carp
they want that jaw full of carp you know
they want to you know they want to fall
asleep at night and have a little bit of
mercury in the back of their tongue
women like Precious Metals
so don't get don't take your lady you
know for a damn couple of hot chicken
wings she's had two of them now her eyes
are watering her makeup's running she
looks like a raccoon that got into a
fight and it was just starting to rain
come on man take your lady by her that
fish dinner bye yeah I'll be as you
dinner you know what I'm saying carp
um [__] scallop mollusk see mollusk
uh Ahi Ahi get your lady what she
deserves dude something that used to
swim and be free
you out there buying that [__] a small
ass wing with some [__] mustard on
the camera
treat her right
give you buy your lady something that
had a hook in it because women like that
fish dinner
women like Precious Metals you know they
want jewelry gold diamonds or you know
shined up ore coppers
you know at least with fish dinner woman
falls asleep at night a little bit of
mercury in her on her tongue a little
bit of that murk murk taste in her mouth
make sure at least feel sometime in her
subconscious like somebody bought our
piece of jewelry so keep your lady off
the wings I used to love that [__] dude
when he was split some some one person
would get it you would just sit by him
you don't think the [__] boss knew oh
you're the weird dude who just sits in a
restaurant with somebody
and doesn't eat but also has food and
crumbs all over their shirt
you're busted man I remember our mom
would take us to this pizza place that
had a buffet and they had all you could
get fresh olives on there they had
probably they had like an olive bar had
three types of Olives which was a lot I
mean this was in the late 90s that was a
lot of Olives you know and we would get
one plate and all walk and hold it at
the same time
like that [__] matter dude four kids
holding one plate
like it's like a Olympic torch
trying to pretend like since we all had
our hand on it that we got the the deal
that it was all you could eat
nothing shadier than that boy that's
growing up real right there
you hiding man eating real fast
you you like uh you're like the James
bondage of digestion
you know you you wait real quick and
then look you know as soon as a manager
looks away or a phone call comes in you
[__] you know
you toothed down a couple of hits or
something gang
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one